ministre de l'éducation avec en netteté
et justice nous sommes à l'époque où
françois legault fait son premier saut
en politique
un ancien professeur livrer cette
profession élimine est mais peut-être un
jour il pourrait devenir prévenu le
premier ministre désigné du québec
françois legault
ça lui aura pris 19 ans on nomme marqué
l'histoire
mais la carrière de françois legault
c'est d'abord le monde des affaires un
état capable de l'ancien au niveau du
tri il cofonde air transat dans les
années 80 et dirige la compagnie
aérienne jusqu'en 97 ce qui fera de lui
un multimillionnaire alors quand bernard
landry le fait entrer au gouvernement
sans être élu monsieur françois lebon
ministre de l'éducation un méga
ministère pour un novice en politique
c'est l'époque où il est souverainiste
souverainistes pressés 10mm certain
monsieur françois legault piliers de
l'équipe péquiste menez d'état à la
santé et aux services sociaux il
présente le budget du québec souverain
et songe même à succéder à bernard
landry avant de renoncer
ma première responsabilité c'est d'être
à l'écouté de ma famille finalement en
2009 il quitte la politique
oui je me raconte j'ai de la difficulté
à à l'opposition a critiqué mots j'aime
mieux construire un gode action avant de
revenir deux ans plus tard je suis très
heureux d'annoncer ce matin le lancement
des activités de la coalition pour
l'avenir du québec
la souveraineté en moins au chapitre de
ses convictions la caq absorbe la dq
vieille de presque 20 ans pour essayer
de relancer québec
élu dans l'assomption en 2012 réélu en
2014 c'est évident à jarret espérer de
meilleurs résultats
ils viendront quatre ans plus tard
20h19 radio canada prévoit que le
prochain gouvernement sera formé par la
coalition avenir québec
[Applaudissements]
si mathieu prost radio canada montréal